[Music]
so
hi i'm shannon bailey the chief curator
at the world chess hall of fame
and here we're looking at our current
exhibition
power and check chess and the american
presidency
it's so fun for us to be able to present
exhibitions
that celebrate our current events and
it was very fitting for us because we
have so many political and presidential
artifacts in our collection
to celebrate the 2020 presidential
election
we have so many different chess sets
it's really great
to be able to pull these out of our
permanent collection and in fact we
actually got great donations for this
just particular
exhibition here we see our presidents
involved in everything
from our our kind of battles with russia
here we have the american revolution
and the civil war because abraham
lincoln
general grant and george washington
were all chess players
we have fun chess sets that look at just
particular races
here we have this very fun cartoony bill
clinton versus bob dole chess set
with really great details including even
bill clinton eating his mcdonald's
we also show a great variety of how
chess sets can be made as well in this
case we've got beautiful carved wood
sets
plastic paper clay and 3d printed
one of our favorite chess sets in this
entire show
is this seemingly simple wooden chest
set here
this set was actually made from a tree
that had to be cut down that was
believed to have been planted
by thomas jefferson at monticello thomas
jefferson
was the most prolific chess playing
president in our entire nation's history
and this tree had to be cut down
and to commemorate its history it was
made into chess sets and some other
beautiful artifacts
we were lucky enough to get the final
chess set for our permanent collection
in this exhibition you get to learn how
every single president of the united
states
was involved with chess some of them
didn't play and some of them were
fantastic chess players
some of them helped promote the game
here we have some really great
artifacts in our collection from gerald
ford and
george bush who we have signed letters
of them
promoting national chess day and
national chess week
this exhibition will be on view through
the inauguration
so if you haven't had a chance to come
down and visit it live
you still have plenty of chance to do
that also you can visit it on our
website
worldchesthof.org